ladies and gentlemen were back with
another episode of manna fest so spread
your wings and prepare to get your feet
wet as we explore the mysteries and new
questions of episode 4 Unclaimed Baggage
tonight's episode revolves around
mysterious flight eight to eight
stowaway Thomas and his relationship
with flight attendant Bethany all the
while Sanvi and Michaela begin to see
eerie hallucinations of a woman made of
stone so who is Thomas why was Bethany
helping him who is the stone lady and
what is her significance episode 4
begins with sahn v as she continues her
research into what exactly is going on
in the brains of the 8 to 8 passengers
as she walks through hallways she sees
wet footprints before being confronted
by a woman made of stone a much more
sinister calling than we've seen before
almost like a jump scare it begs the
question are all callings good later
sonn V shows a brain scan to her
co-worker a scan we can only assume as
her own to gain some insight on what
might be happening in her own brain
during these hallucinations
he explains there's brain activity in
the insular cortex consistent with
someone who experiences hallucinations
but not much is known about this area
side note the insular cortex is believed
to be connected to our consciousness and
plays a role in our emotions such as
compassion empathy and perception it is
also believed to be connected to motor
control self-awareness cognitive
functioning and interpersonal experience
interpersonal experiences are the strong
deep or close association or
acquaintance between two or more people
like the connection between the
passengers of eight to eight so calling
all brain surgeons that may be watching
fill us in with some more info in the
comment section after looking at the
brain scan Sandy's co-worker explains
there's a homeless man in room 810 with
similar brain readings as she goes to
visit him she sees more wet footprints
before our stowaway Thomas comes
bursting out of the room rambling about
Bethany the flight attendant meanwhile
Mikayla on stakeout with her ex-fiance
Jared also experiences a hallucination
with the stone lady this time however
she isn't wet but has wings she speaks
to Mikayla saying save him which
Michaela confuses as meaning saved the
man on their stakeout this leads to a
bus gone wrong and a whole lot of
trouble for Michaela and Jared
as Salm V searches for answers about
Thomas she meets with Bethany the flight
attendant turns out Thomas's her cousins
lover who is doubling as a flight
attendant while trying to escape
persecution as a gay man in Jamaica when
they go to smuggle him out
Thomas escaped since on V and Bethany
rushed to find him before the government
does Sean V gets a clue from the water
footprints which leads her to Michaela
as they puzzle over where Thomas might
have gone Michaela and Sandra realized
they've been seeing the same
hallucination but with one difference
Sean V saw the stone lady with wet feet
and Michaela saw her with wings this
clicks and Bethany is the Angel of the
waters a statue of an angel on top of
the Bethesda Fountain in Central Park
this fountain is a big part of angels in
America appeal at surprise and Tony
award-winning play by Tony Kushner the
play also happened to be Thomas's
partner Leo's favorite play and where
they were gonna meet up after flight 8
to 8 was scheduled to land and lo and
behold there's Thomas at the fountain
scared and freaking out about missing
his partner Leo and five and a half
years of his life Sean V Michaela and
Bethany take Thomas to safety and
another calling is complete this time it
took both the callings of Sandy and
Michaela the different angels to work
together to solve it sound familiar all
things work together for good it's
becoming apparent that there's a
connection between these passengers and
that these callings are starting to pull
them all together likely for some
unknown ultimate goal where they will
have to unite for good just like they
all felt compelled to meet at the plane
and watch it explode and just like the
connection Michaela had with Shadow
victim Kelly Taylor and they are calling
on your truth but what's the
significance of the Angel of the waters
why this particular message and calling
I believe it was used for a very
specific reason the Bethesda Fountain in
New York takes inspiration from the Pool
of Bethesda and Jerusalem and more
specifically from an event called the
healing of a paralytic at Bethesda the
healing was an event that occurs
exclusively in the Gospel of John where
Jesus Christ miraculously heals a
paralyzed man at the pool along the
fountain in New York there are four
four-foot cherubs representing
temperance purity health and peace and
is referring to the Croton Aqueduct the
first dependable supply of clean water
for the city of New York it was and is a
symbol of Health and healing powers just
like the Pool of Bethesda was
to be blessed by God with healing waters
I touched on this a bit in episode 1 of
exploring manifests but could all these
passengers be in need of some sort of
healing or penance
could these callings be a way to become
cleansed whether it be a cleansing of a
physical ailment like cows cancer or
some sort of emotional burden
remember what Isaiah said to Michaela
last episode to unburden herself the
fountain itself also plays a large role
in angels of America a play which
examines aids and homosexuality in 1980s
America and is largely argued to be one
of the most important pieces of theatre
written in the 20th century many of the
characters in the play battle with AIDS
and begin to experience ghostly visions
and the appearance of angels the
character prior Walter is also described
by the angels as a prophet or carrying a
prophecy and that his mortal illness is
what has caused this prophecy in these
visions to manifest in him in Episode
two I touched on the idea that cow could
be some sort of Savior or perhaps now a
prophet at the end of the play the
characters gather at the Bethesda
Fountain and prior talks about the
healing of the paralytic at Bethesda
pool here the play discusses albeit
metaphorically the courage to face
changes despite not knowing the outcome
and the play ends on a note of hope not
unlike the characters are manifest who
are now experiencing great changes since
landing five years in the future and
certainly are leaping into the unknown
but more obvious is the fountain itself
a giant symbolic angel yet another nod
to religion in the connection between
these callings and a greater power
that's it for this week's episode of
exploring manifest I hope you enjoyed
the video and if you did make sure to
LIKE and subscribe I also have a Twitter
account where you can get updates on my
latest videos remember if you have any
new and exciting theories on the show
please feel free to comment below so I
can pull an olive and shove it in my
backpack to use for the next video